.
Thank you.
I don't know if this is recorded.
So I think I put everything that was asked for in the thing in there.
I have asked my caucus, and everybody is totally cool with this.
I think we could go consent.
I did screw one thing up on here.
I forgot to put the effective date.
Oh, okay.
Okay, and so that I really did want to ask you guys.
I'm in a town council form of government, so we're able to react faster.
You guys are all, I think a lot of you are SB2.
What do you guys, what do you want?
I would say from my perspective, I think the original effective date of 60 days is fine with this type of legislation because the town has to adopt it irregardless.
So for them to update they'll still have the opportunity.
This becomes law.
This will give them some time to educate everybody prior to that portion of it being updated.
But one way or the other it goes through.
You know, that's me.
I don't have a problem.
I mean, I usually come up on a warrant out of the plan.
I mean, I think usually all of us come up on a warrant out of the front line, so they may still do that.
I don't know.
I mean, I'm going to – so I'm totally fine with that, honestly.
So it would be 60 days from this.
All right, so here's the question.
I do need to put this back into OLS, but is everybody fine with this language with 60 days?
I'm good i'm good my my only comment about the existing language was um 51 of the properties are in a thousand i have it on but it's not picking up my voice um 51 of the properties went in a thousand foot radius and then built before the effective date of this section that requires keeping track of the effective date when all the properties were built i mean i would be okay with just within a thousand foot radius period and then you'll have to keep track of all that extra stuff the only reason we did that this will do creep and i think that met resistance if we do it with this language it would be unanimous i don I don't think it's not going to be that hard because you're going to have to go do the research anyway, so it's going to come up, so it's not that big a thing, but it stops creep.
And again, I think that it will be totally unanimous.
It'll go through consent.
Fair enough.
Okay.
Line 13.
Are we good?
So I will say I'll lead with you or I'll go with what you think is best to get it to put forward.
I do think that there may be a time coming forward where you you want to take that out only because if the towns continue to implement zoning the way they were which is what this is intended to fix then i think it'll have there'll be some negative effects from it but i think overall this is a huge improvement yeah i think we're going to come back to this honestly we didn't do that patterns the zoning we didn't get.
And I think for us, we should strongly consider bipartisanly working on that and adding, exactly adding to this.
I think this is just the first step.
It's going to give relief, but we can do better.
Yeah.
Okay.
Agreed.
All right.
If that's the case, it's unanimous and we're done.
I'll write this up.
I'll submit this to OLS, and I think we got something finished.
Should we formally just make sure because we haven't heard from everyone, everybody like raise your hands if you agree.
I should probably do you know a roll call vote.
Representative Gibbs.
No.
today no we'll say i did Thank you.
Yeah, we are going to add the effective date to that, so that doesn't have the effective date on there.
Well, we're done with that.
Yeah.
Well, the Republicans are having a caucus in here at 930.
You do.
Thank you.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America, and to the republic for which it stands, one mission, among God, indisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Okay, so today we have one bill that I've noticed for an exec.
That's an early bill.
We will absolutely get that out of committee today.
And the rest of them, there's a list of them that I'd like to take care of today in conferring with the ranking member, trying to get some of these bills on the calendar so that we do not have a lot of debates at the end of March when the calendar fills up.
So hopefully we can get through a bunch of these today.
So the first thing is I'm going to open up the exec session on HB 572, and I'll recognize Representative Page for a motion.
I would move on to pass.
Okay.
Is there a second?
I'll second it.
Or Representative Kerwin, did you want to second it?
Oh, sure.
All right.
Representative Kerwin will second.
And then I would like to offer Amendment 0560H.
Representative Kerwin, you second that?
Okay.
So the motion by Representative Page ought to pass with Amendment No.
0560H, seconded by Representative Kerwin.
Would you like to speak to the motion?
Sure, yes.
I think everybody agrees that this proposed program can contribute a lot to our efforts to increase our housing supply here in the state of new hampshire i think recognizing that this is the challenging budget environment uh that it is that this is probably the version of this bill that we can get passed this year which is to get the program up and off the ground but to keep that appropriation manageable in this particular budget environment representative you also um you're so I had sat down with the sponsor of this and indicated that the appropriation of ten and a half million dollars for housing champion probably is not in the cards so to speak for well I can't predict what house finance is gonna do but I have a better around long enough to to know.
So what we did is we took out the Housing Champion Grant Fund Program designation, and we maintained one appropriation of $150,000 to create a municipal – establishing a compilation of municipal and county-owned property determined appropriate for residential development by the select board.
So that's going to hopefully get a database together that, you know, when people are looking for residential development properties, hopefully the towns will opt in and give us this information.
Additionally, it gives some new power to review site plans.
um this is an enabling legislation so it allows um if the local legislative body of the municipality um has authorized it um it authorizes a bypass of the minor site plan review um so hopefully that will help speed up the approval process in some ways so um i like represent page said there there were some merits to this bill I just was concerned primarily about the appropriation.
That's no longer in it.
There's a much smaller appropriation in there.
So this will go off to finance, but at least it will get our endorsement before it does.
Any other comments?
All right.
Is show of hands on the amendment okay?
Oh, I haven't called it yet.
All right.
All those in favor of adopting amendment number 2025-0560H, raise your hand now.
Those opposed.
Abstentions?
No abstentions.
Sorry, I'm thinking I'm on the local budget committee.
That passes unanimous.
All right.
So we're on the motion of ought to pass as amended.
Is there any comments on that?
Seeing none, I'll call the roll.
Vice Chairman Cole?
Yes.
Representative Thaxton?
Representative Aaron?
Yes.
Representative Bollier?
Representative Dumont?
Yes.
Representative Grant?
Representative Miles, not Yes.
Yes.
Representative Miles?
Not here.
Representative Miner?
Yes.
Clerk Reinfert?
Representative Page?
Yes.
Representative Boras?
As Representative Seibert?
Yep.
Okay, so do I say both names or just?
No, just our name.
Okay.
Representative Seibert?
Yes.
just our name.
Okay.
Representative Seibert.
Yes.
Representative Reed, not here.
Representative Gibbs.
Yes.
Representative Hicks.
Representative Howland.
Yes.
Representative Hagner.
Representative Kerwin.
Yes.
And Chairman Alexander.
Motion carries 16 to 0.
Representative Page, will you write the majority report?
Good pleasure.
All right.
And any objection?
This might be on the regular calendar.
I have to check with the fiscal note.
It probably will be on the regular calendar.
Cannot call and consent because of the appropriation.
There's $150,000 appropriation.
All right.
So that will probably go on the regular calendar.
Next up, I want to have a conversation on HB 296.
I don't think we're ready for a vote on it, but I at least want to recognize Representative Dumont to speak to an amendment that you had drafted and some of the conversations around that.
So I passed around an amendment.
It's pretty straightforward.
It just basically says that, you know, private roads built to town standards shall be treated the same way as laws that are on town roads.
The only thing that I'd like to add in there on line seven after the word private roads is or class six roads.
That way it's basically, you know, existing roadways that aren't maintained by a town and or private roadways that are built to the town standards are treated the same way as ones with frontage on uh on regular town roads other discussion on that is everybody okay with with that amendment when that's drafted all right represent howlin i was I was just going to say, I think it's good.
I mean, our one concern really was that please don't build, like, private roads that are, like, substandard out there and go a stretch.
We really want the new ones to be more conforming, like you said.
It'll solve so many problems.
I think this is a really good change.
Great.
Okay, so I'm not going to call the exec.
We're going to get an amendment drafted, and hopefully we can do something really quick in a couple weeks and take care of that.
Okay, next up, I want to open up the executive session on HB 342 and recognize Representative Howland.
I guess that's me.
They are.
Wow.
All right.
So I'm digging through my papers.
We just did this this morning.
So this one, in the past, what this was going to do is.
I would make a motion first.
I would like to make a motion to pass.
Where's my.
Through all these papers.
I know I haven't.
Yes.
0579H.
That's page.
All right.
So I'd like to make a motion to pass the amendment for House Bill 342.
So your motion would be ought to pass?
Ought to pass.
And then you're going to move an amendment.
And then I would like to move the amendment, which is House Bill 342-0579H.
I second the ought to pass.
All right.
So Representative Page seconds your ought to pass motion.
Representative Howland offers amendment 0579H.
And I second the amendment.
And Representative Reid seconds that.
Representative Howland, would you like to speak to your amendment?
All right, let me pull it out.
All right.
I'm sorry for the confusion.
So we met, and when we went over it, initially what this was going to do is if you threw out a 1,000-foot buffer, that anything within that, you did within your thousand foot buffer, that anything within that you did within your thousand foot buffer, if you could show that the lot size that you wanted to do conformed with what was in that thousand foot buffer, initially it was 90%, then you could do it.
you would be issued a variance and then the planning board would look at your density report and see if it was okay and let you build it and so uh the changes that we made on it um i still don't have my like right sheet so what we said we didn't want it so that you were bypassing the um the zba and so instead what we said is you could do the thousand foot uh buffer uh you were able to use a majority rather than 90 percent of the properties within that thousand foot buffer and we said that they would be you it would only be properties that had been built before this uh had been in place so we didn't want zones to keep creeping indefinitely.
If you did that, you would go to your town administrator.
The town administrator would verify that you actually met the lot coverage of 51% in that buffer, and they would issue you a building permit.
So it would expedite the building permit it would allow your property to conform to what is in that thousand foot buffer and uh we thought that it's a good infill bill so it really simplified stuff and then the effective date of it is 60 days do you have an the amendment um i i have the amendment in I have the amendment in my...
Does the committee have copies of the amendment?
I gave it to the committee.
Everybody in the committee had copies.
Oh, okay.
I've got to get organized then.
Other comments on this?
No, it's okay.
I probably have a copy of you.
Thank you.
Okay, other comments?
Representative Bolio or Dumont or Grant, you were all part of the subcommittee.
Representative Dumont.
Yeah, I think that this worked out really great.
Basically what it does is it takes existing lots of records that conform to the neighborhood and allows them to be built by right.
It also adds an avenue for lots that may be oversized in those neighborhoods to be subdivided and go in front of the planning board and not have to go in front of the zoning board.
So I think the spirit of the of the bill is met and allows for more housing to be to be built in a neighborhood that already conforms but is just based on today's zoning regulations forced to follow a different step.
All right any other comments?
Show of hands okay for the amendment?
All right.
I haven't called it yet.
All those in favor of amendment number 2025-05-79H, raise your hand now.
Those opposed?
All right.
That's unanimous.
That's adopted.
So now we're on the ought to pass as amended motion.
Are there comments on this?
All right.
I'll let the clerk organized and as soon as she's ready the motion is ought to pass as amended with um 0579h vice chairman cole yes representative faxton representative aaron yes representative Yes.
Representative Dumont.
Yes.
Representative.
Representative Aaron.
Yes.
Representative Bollier.
Representative Dumont.
Yes.
Representative Grant.
Representative Miles Absent.
Representative Miner.
Yes.
Clerk Reinfert.
Representative Page.
Yes.
Representative Siebert.
Representative Reed.
Yes.
Representative Gibbs.
Representative Hicks.
Yes.
Representative Howland.
Representative Hegner.
Yes.
Representative Kerwin.
And Chairman Alexander.
Yes.
Motion carries 17 to 0.
Representative Howland, would you like to write the majority report?
Okay, and is there any objection to this bill going on consent?
See, now we'll put that on consent.
So if you can get that to me Like by the end of today, maybe early tomorrow.
That'd be great.
Thank you Okay, next up is each I'm gonna open up the executive session on HB 382.
I'm gonna recognize myself for a I'm going to move ought to pass.
Is there a second?
Second by Representative Cole, and I'm going to offer amendment.
I've got to get organized.
Mr.
Chairman, do you have copies of this amendment?
I know you sent it by email, but...
I thought you were passing it around, Representative.
Is it over there?
I think this is the event.
I just had a bunch of copies.
They're sitting here somewhere.
I was going to say, I know who I passed.
The amendment number is 0687H.
It should be coming around.
I had copies made.
Do you guys have them?
You're all set.
Okay.
Representative Dumont, where'd you...
Did we lose them somewhere right here you had to be that guy Wow that's what I'll I do to make sure you know that's not right yeah that's not it.
0687.
Does anybody have 0687?
All right.
We're going to recess for five minutes to get organized.
Thank you.
Okay, so as I was saying, I recognize myself to make a motion of ought to pass, and it's second by Representative Aaron or Cole.
Cole.
And I'm going to move Amendment 2025-0687H.
Is there a second to that?
I'll second.
Second by Representative Page.
So to briefly speak to this amendment, I enjoy the underlying bill.
I think it's a great bill.
But I also am a man of consensus, and I think that this will help move the needle.
I think municipalities do arbitrarily mandate parking spaces in order to zone out certain dwellings in a community, and I think that's completely unfair.
I also think that these Black Friday parking situations where you mandate hundreds of spots for a Walmart that it's going to be full one day a year, I think really does hurt the environmental impact, but also costs more on businesses.
And I want to be pro-business, and I want to support the property rights.
I think the free market is the best determinant over how many parking spaces are needed.
If there's not enough parking, people will not go to that business.
People will not live in that development.
But I think the free market is the best determinant, not an arbitrary number that's thrown out by us or anybody else.
So I'm moving this because this amendment will replace the bill, but it adds it restricts municipalities right to regulate more than one residential parking space per unit.
This is a carbon copy of HB 1400 that was passed last biennium on the consent calendar in the House.
And then the committee of conference last year that I chaired, we ended up getting to a consensus with the other body for this language.
I would like to strike the language and go back to the original bill that we had.
So with that, I'm open to comments.
Representative Bolio.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I completely agree with the comments that you made, and I would just like to add, you know, this isn't just some, you know, oh, hey, we're, you know, playing around with the number of parking spaces.
The fact is, is New Hampshire is in a very, very serious housing crisis, is in a cost of living crisis.
And anything that we can do to empower the free market to deliver additional housing, I think, is something that should be seriously considered by the legislature.
and you know despite the fact that nobody likes to hunt around for parking space, I think at the end of the day, we all want a New Hampshire.
You know, if we had a choice, which New Hampshire do you want to live in a New Hampshire that has enough housing or New Hampshire that has enough parking?
I think we should prioritize our friends and neighbors and we should advocate for a New Hampshire thathire that has enough housing before we worry about if new hampshire has enough parking representative reed my hand up but i'll say something because you saw it in my eyes and perhaps you knew what i was imagining when uh the representative from what's your town littleton, said what he said, because I remember a year ago saying the words and getting gaveled for them, that we have a housing crisis, not a parking crisis.
So I agree.
I personally don't always think the free market is the best, but I acknowledge that it can be in certain situations.
Having said that, this is specific to residential, so I think one per residential unit is sufficient.
Any other comments?
Is the show of hands on the amendment okay?
All right, don't raise your hand yet.
All those in favor of adopting Amendment 2025-0687H, raise your hand now.
All those opposed.
Amendment passes unanimous.
We're now on the ought to pass as amended.
Are there comments on that?
All right, seeing none, I'm going to have the clerk call the roll.
The motion is ought to pass as amended with HB 382 with Amendment 0687H.
The clerk's moving me nervous standing over there.
Vice Chairman Cole?
Yes.
Representative Thaxton?
Representative Aaron?
Yes.
Representative Bullier?
Representative Dumont?
Yes.
Representative Grant?
Representative Miles?
Not here.
Representative Minor?
Yes.
Clerk Re Reinfert.
Representative Page.
Yes.
Representative Siebert.
Representative Reed.
Yes.
Representative Gibbs.
Representative Hicks.
Yes.
Representative Howland.
Representative Hegner.
Yes.
Representative Kerwin.
Chairman Alexander.
Yes.
Motion carries 17 to 0.
Is there any objection to this going on the consent calendar?
All right.
Seeing none, I'm going to put it on the consent calendar, and I will write the report to go on the calendar.
With that, I would like to – I want to have a – I want to open up the executive session on HB465 and I'm going to recognize Representative Dumont for a motion make a motion to retain motion by Representative Dumont to retain is there a second second by Representative Aaron would you like to speak to that just simply put I think it has good merit I just would like to work on it a little bit okay nice and quick Thank you.
to that?
Just simply put, I think it has good merit.
I just would like to work on it a little bit.
Okay.
Nice and quick.
Alright, any other discussion on that?
Seeing none, I'm going to have the clerk call the roll when she's ready.
Vice Chairman Cole?
Yes.
Representative Thaxton?
Representative Maya Aaron?
Yes.
Representative Beaulieu?
Representative Thaxton?
Yes.
Representative Aaron?
Representative Beaulieu?
Yes.
Representative Dumont?
Representative Grant?
Yes.
Representative Miles, not here.
Representative Minor?
Yes.
Clerk Reinfort?
Representative Page?
Yes.
Representative Sebert?
Representative Reed?
Yes.
Representative Sebert.
Representative Reed.
Yes.
Representative Gibbs.
Representative Hicks.
Yes.
Representative Howland.
Representative Hegner.
Yes.
Representative Kerwin.
Chairman Alexander.
Yes.
Motion carries 17 to 0.
No report needed.
We're just going to retain this for the the fall the summer okay uh the next bill i'd like to call up is hb 631 relative to permitting residential building and commercial zoning by right and i want to call on representative page for a motion move out to pass representative page moves ought.
Is there a second?
Second by Representative Howland.
Go ahead.
Representative Page.
All right.
Sure.
I'd also like to move Amendment 0667H.
Do you have a different one than me?
I circulated one.
Oh, okay.
This is exactly what I sent via email other than the typo on line 11.
Is there a second to that motion?
A second.
Okay, second by Representative Reed.
Go ahead.
Great.
Yes, and this is exactly the same amendment that I sent the committee by email, but the word zone has been corrected to zoned where there was that typo on line 11 and that's the only change that was made so i think i i appreciated the intent of this bill as we dug into it it seemed like there were more and more pieces of it that were unworkable as introduced but i'm hopeful that we've reached something workable here we tried to make sure that we still empowered municipalities to restrict residential development where there might be industrial uses in various commercial zones that were really incompatible with residential use.
And we also, one of the things that came up in the committee hearing was around the use of the ground floor and really trying to ensure that municipalities could still keep the spirit of sort of village districts where you would have commercial areas.
So we empowered municipalities to have, you know, make those determinations about how the ground floor would be used in the districts.
So we tried to ensure that we would control for those concerns that came up in the hearing while also pushing forward with the spirit of the bill, which is really to get more mixed-use development.
And I'm supportive of the goal and I hope this is a workable amendment for the committee.
Other comments?
Representative Bolio.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I just wanted to say, I mean, I really, really, really appreciate the spirit and intention of this bill.
I think, you know, mixed-use development is something which has historically occurred in New Hampshire.
I am very fortunate to be a resident of the town of Littleton.
For those of you who have been to Littleton, we have a very charming, you know, Main Street that is, you know, excellent, you know, retail.
It's walkable.
But if you look above all of those charming shops on Main Street, there are apartments.
There are houses.
so I think this is something that's not just unique to Littleton you see it again and again throughout our state and I think that it is a historic pattern of development in New Hampshire that should be welcomed and encouraged it's kind of nice if you are a city person to choose to live in an apartment and walk to the corner coffee shop and get a coffee.
So I think we should really, really encourage mixed-use development as part of the many things we can do to address New Hampshire's housing crisis.
All right.
Is the show of hands okay on the amendment?
The motion is by Representative Page to move Amendment 2025-0667H.
If you're in favor of Representative Page's amendment, raise your hand now.
Opposed?
All right.
Amendment passes.
We're now on the ought to pass as amended with 0-667H.
Is there any more discussion on that?
All right.
Seeing none, we'll have the clerk call the roll.
Vice Chairman Cole?
Yes.
Representative Thaxton?
Representative Aaron?
Yes.
Representative Bullyer?
Representative Dumont?
Yes.
Representative Grant?
Representative Miles?
Not here.
Representative Miner?
Yes.
Clerk Reinfort?
Representative Page?
Yes.
Representative Siebert, yes.
Representative Reed, yes.
Representative Gibbs, yes.
Representative Hicks, yes.
Representative Howland, yes.
Representative Hegner, yes.
Representative Kerwin, yes.
Chairman Alexander, yes.
Motion carries 17 to 0.
Is there an objection to this going on consent?
Seeing no, we're going to put it on consent.
Representative Page, would you like to write that report, or do you want somebody else to?
Do I have any volunteers?
If you don't want to do it, I'll do it.
All right.
Okay.
I may ask for the bullet points you want me to include.
All right representative will write the report okay so that bill will go on consent um next up i want to have a quick discussion on hb 457 although i'm not ready to open the exec on it um i think the hearing was very interesting.
Let me find my amendment.
I think what's going on in Durham is a situation that I think is excessive government overreach.
And I think that in some ways the state needs to say that this is excessive government overreach, regulating who can live in what bedroom and what lifestyle somebody has.
I just think that isn't really a government business.
So I have an amendment.
I'm not ready to move it yet because there are a couple of things brought up.
Representative Dumont at one point mentioned the concern with sober houses and single-family neighborhoods and about how you may have non-familiar status and relationship, and that's not really necessarily what we want to deal with in this committee.
There's other committees for that, so I want to kind of get together with a few people and work on an amendment that will address that.
But is there other feedback?
Representative Gibbs, go ahead.
Thank you.
I've sponsored House Bill 432, which is in municipal and county government, which specifies that recovery houses, what includes sober houses, are to be treated the same as any other residents.
And that's in municipal county government.
They haven't finished with it yet.
But I should point out that under the Federal Fair Housing Act, recovery houses are required to be treated the same as other types of housing.
Otherwise, you would have discrimination against people with a disability.
Representative Howland.
So I've had this conversation.
So in state fire code and life safety code, occupancy for almost everything is square foot per occupant.
There are two exceptions.
There's single family home and there's lodging houses.
And it's created because of that, neither of which has a square foot per occupant, it creates a lot of confusion.
And I've seen this conversation for nine years and i've seen it botched every single time so i'll start out with it's how many people can you fit in a single family house families are defined by the municipality so there is a family you can put as many people in there as long as you meet sewer the state sewer waters you're going gonna have to pull a permit for that but there is no square footage for a family if you look in fire code in 618.1 it defines what a single family house is and that's really important because definitions define where you put them in your table of uses and where you let them in your community.
And so a single family house is defined as it allows members of a single family and no more than three outsiders.
In Fire Code, they tried to clarify that also because we had like students coming here and they said, look, we just want to we want to share a house.
And there's a bunch of us and we want to share a house.
Well, when you get past three unrelated people, it is no longer classified as a single family house.
It undergoes a change of use.
It becomes a lodging or rooming house.
And that's really important because that dictates where your community will allow them.
All right.
And so that's created all kinds of issues.
I heard like discrimination against students.
In Durham, students can and do rent anywhere in our community, anywhere there's an apartment.
They're going to ask you for a guarantor so you can actually do the rent, but they can rent anywhere.
But we do not allow lodging houses in our zones.
To answer the question of this legislation that was proposed, which is no less than two beds per occupant.
So before this legislation, if it were to go through, how many people could fit, how many unrelated people could fit in a single family home?
Three.
After this legislation goes through, how many unrelated people could fit in a single family home?
And the answer is three.
Because at three, it is no longer a single familyfamily house it undergoes a change of use when you undergo that change of use to become a lodging house it first requires you buy its RSA 485 A38 you're gonna have to show that you can handle the increased capacity of your septic the second thing it's gonna require and that.3.6.1, is you're going to have to put in a sprinkler system.
All right.
And so the problem with this is there's no square footage in a lodging house.
A lodging house, once you said yes, you could have a lodging house, a lodging house can have up to 16 people in it.
All right.
And so in this case where she's saying two per bedroom, well, if you're putting in a sprinkling system, which under the cheapest condition, if you're doing it, we're hooked up to sewer and water, it's probably going to cost you north of $30,000.
You're going to have a high incentive to try to cut that house up and get as many people in as possible and you can all the way up to 16 there's nothing in there so this says no less than two per bedroom well you can have an open concept and call it a bedroom and put 16 people in that house there's nothing to stop that and so uh it really makes it challenging for a municipality to say, yes, we do want to allow lodging houses in these areas.
And Representative Gibbs' bill actually shows how difficult that is.
So addiction is classified as a disability, and it's covered.
They're a protected class under the American Disabilities Act.
All right.
But it's still hard to get a recovery house done.
Her bill, what it really says, is not that you can allow recovery houses anywhere.
What it's saying is we're going to treat the addicted residents as a family.
And therefore, that single-family house does not undergo a change of use.
It does not become a lodging house.
It stays as a single family house.
And why that's important is because single family houses are allowed in all residential, almost all residential zones.
And therefore, if you do it that way, the recovery house skirts the need to actually go through the lodging house standard.
And so that's a problem.
So that recovery house that you would do there then because they're classified as a family there is no square footage per occupant a lot that is required so you can really put a lot of people in that house and so that meets a lot of resistance and that in municipal county is dealing with that and so i just talked to the sponsor before we started this about this i i totally understand the intent of this because we do need lodging houses lodging houses are recovery houses lodging houses can be transitional housing lodging houses could be a shelter for battered women but it is extremely difficult under the current way that is defined particularly with no square footage attached to it for a community to say yes i've talked to representative um fracked who's on the subcommittee over there that's working on the recovery houses and as i say i just talked to representative power i think we we definitely can do better than the two per per bedroom we need to come up with clarifying what the square footage is i don't know what that is offhand and i think we really need a group that has some experience in planning to sit down and work on it and craft something that's better this bill just doesn't do it in durham the reason that we do not allow lodging houses is not because we discriminate against students.
During the committee meeting, we heard a lot about student behavior.
In 2014, Durham really allowed a lot of construction of student apartments in our downtown.
And it's not in an industrial zone.
It's near campus.
Most people that visit say it's a really nice area.
Why we did that is because if you allow a lodging house and you can allow up to 16 people in it, and essentially what was a single-family house, what happens, it drives up the aggregate rent and a family cannot rent that house.
It really boxes out families from buying single family houses and we don't want that.
And that's why we put it in place.
In terms of student behavior, when we put in well-managed apartments, we put in a community police officer that works with the deans.
We've seen a, and the large apartments that we put in, if you're familiar with Durham, across from where our frats are, what used to be kind of some rundown green apartments, we put in Madbury Commons.
Madbury Commons is 732 beds of housing.
When you come downhill from where the church is, it's called Church Hill, we put in the campus flats.
That's 768 beds of student housing.
We also put in Ted Madbury, which is another 100.
They're all really well-managed apartment complexes that have on-site security.
we've seen again a dramatic decline we used to i don't know if any of you are you know young enough to remember what cinco de mayo was in the early 2000s uh or any of you had any idea of like how many on a week how many students on a weekend would get tagged for internal uh possession of alcohol it could be up to a per each day.
We've seen that decline to almost nothing.
And why is that?
Because managed departments, along with a community police officer, along working with UNH, has really solved what was a behavioral problem.
So it's a red herring to say it's a behavior issue.
What it really is, is we don't like it because the per bed pricing and the unrestricted up to 16 that you would allow in a single family house means that families cannot rent or buy those houses.
And so that's why we're not allowing it just to try to address what we've seen is the the issue for the missing middle we put in workforce housing overlays the workforce housing overlay that we've had has upwards of 200 units and all of those units would be tied to fmr fair market rent uh we think that that really will provide additional housing that will meet more needs and so while i appreciate the sentiment of the bill it doesn't really fix anything a community can still say we don't want lodging houses and and you won't have lodging houses a single family house if you put the two bedroom rule in place you can actually only fill one bedroom and one person in the other bedroom.
If you have a four-bedroom house, you're not going to fill all four bedrooms.
So it doesn't fix the issue.
That's my two cents.
Okay.
Other comments?
All right.
Well, with that information, I'm going to hold off for a few weeks on this.
Not sure what I want to do.
Maybe a retain, something like that.
We'll see how it goes.
but we have so what's left in this committee's hands that we have not represent page I just I wanted to just piggybacking on some of what representative Howland said I think it's interesting that we have another bill and another committee that deals with the same lodging house issue Just piggybacking on some of what Representative Howland said, I think it's interesting that we have another bill and another committee that deals with the same lodging house issues.
I don't know how we would structure it, but I wonder if there might be a way to connect our work on this bill with the work that's happening on that bill.
Whether we retain it, I don't know that we have time to do a subcommittee now, but I would think that these are very connected bills and connected issues, and it would be wise for us to be working in tandem.
I agree with you.
Let me confer with Representative Power and see where she's at on that bill.
So we have the bills that we have not yet acted on.
We have three left HP 296, which we went over today, that's relative to the The bills that we have not yet acted on, we have three left.
HB 296, which we went over today, that's relative to the building permits along roads.
HB 410, there's a subcommittee at 1 o'clock today.
Representative Reid will be heading that up.
And then HB 457 that we have just discussed.
The rest of the bills that we have left in our possession we have retained.
So we can focus on doing work on those or not over the summer.
Other than that, that's what we're going to get our Senate bills.
So my hope is hopefully if we can have a quick exec during a session day or something like that, so I don't have to pull the committee back for a full like 30 less than 30 minutes of work um would probably be best so I'm thinking about doing some sort of uh executive session I'll announce that on a session day and I'll confer with representative page so it's not like I surprise my friends across the aisle so thank you um that's not how we do things here all right anything Anything else before this committee?
Okay.
Thank you.
Have a good day, George.
Hi, y'all.
We're going to convene the subcommittee on HB 410.
So, there was a lot of feedback during the hearing of things that needed to be improved.
Language, it seems like everybody's on board with the general gist.
I've had the Institute of Justice as well as Mercatus give their feedback and told them about the different aspects that were brought up during the hearing.
And so this is a print of a Google Doc that those parties had access to.
I did send out a slightly older version of this to everybody just so you knew what was being discussed.
So just from the top, and then we can get into like different ideas and what we all think.
So one of the things was really tightening up the language on what the heck this evidence that a town a town would have to provide so we switch it to the governing body which as i understand it and i'm happy to recognize brody if he needs to correct me in most towns the legislative body is the people the governing body is the select board or council but in, no?
And turn on your mic when you speak.
Yeah, these are, I believe these are streamed.
They're noticed.
They have to be noticed.
So.
Okay, I could be wrong.
I don't know that the legislative body and the governing body, I believe, are one and the same.
In some towns.
So what I had explained to me is that, and maybe you're the one who did this, so maybe you should take over, but that in some towns, depending on the charter, you can switch the legislative body to be one and the same as the governing body.
So since we have something, so the best way to describe it, governing body and legislative body is a role, and your municipality delegates what those roles are.
So in some cases, the governing body will be the select board, and then the voters are the legislative body.
In my town, which is a town charter, they've delegated.
So the town council is both the governing body and the legislative body.
So that's why.
So the best way is there are a role in your community decides who does those roles.
Is that a halfway decent way?
So on this bill, do you want to make it legislative slash governing body?
So I think maybe I'll just talk to OLS lawyer to be extra clear on it.
But my understanding is, so for example, the state, the legislative body isn't the voters.
We are the legislative body.
And then there's a governing body in the other branch, right?
So in a smaller traditional town, the legislative body is the people and the governing body is the select board.
But what I understand from Al is that in some cities, just like in the state level, you shift the legislative body up to the elected officials.
In the cities, you would shift the legislative body up to the city council, and then you would have a mayor in addition to that.
You can do it.
So in a town charter— Are you itching to...
I'm not itching, but...
I will recognize Brody DeShase from NHMA.
Thank you.
So it gets complicated with charters because when you have a charter, a city charter, a town charter, the way that they do delegate what is a legislative body and what is a governing body is dictating their charter.
Now, if you're not chartered, which is a vast majority of municipalities throughout the state, your legislative body are the voters, the people who go to town meeting, whether it's SB2 and you go to the first session, the second session by ballot, or you go to the entire town meeting.
So using governing body here, most municipalities would probably mean your board of selectmen.
Now, considering this is a land use issue, what you might be trying to cite is like a specific land use board as defined in RSA 62, 672, I should say.
So using that definition or, you know, choosing one of those land use boards that municipalities that have zoning are allowed to adopt, that I think is the intent.
I could be incorrect, but from what I remember from the hearing on House Bill 410, your goal was that there was some kind of way for people to have redress with that land use board.
Not specifically the Board of selectmen who have very limited control over land usage and not the legislative body because the legislative body in most municipalities is the people.
So I'm from a town council and in my town it works as everything comes from the planning board and goes through the town council.
Everything ultimately goes to the town council.
Is that not the case with a select board no no so in my town it's it's it's my i'm an sb2 town and this is true for you know non-sb2 towns but the planning board crafts warrant articles gotcha they have a hearing they then present them to the legislative body either at the town meeting if it's traditional or via the ballot um at the second session and then me as part of the legislative body, either at the town meeting, if it's traditional, or via the ballot at the second session.
And then me as part of the legislative body, you know, and the other voters, we say yay or nay to those zoning ordinance changes.
So I'm looking at an amendment on a different bill in the language OLS gave me, and I'll just substitute governing body.
I'll say governing body or local land use board may or shall or whatever that is that would that be language that covers the intended i think for your intent it might also be worth um citing the specific rsas for what each one would cover under like for example you might want to cite in like you know governing board under rsa you know for those that are chartered communities or land usage board under RSA, you know, and I believe it's 672 colon might be one, but don't hold me on that.
Representative Dax, can you add your hand up?
No, go ahead.
I think that's all you guys need me for, right?
Thanks.
My concern is that we're going to create a problem where there isn't one because we're not quite sure what the right wording is, because I would respectfully disagree with what was just said.
In SB2 towns and in town meeting towns, so in the specific case of my town, the planning board proposes zoning changes.
They have their hearings.
That's fine.
However, the select board in a town meeting town, it's the selectman's warrant, and we can put whatever we as a selectman, we can craft a zoning change and put it on the warrant, whether the planning board likes it or not.
And you can also put, I just did it, so I know I can do it.
No, there's a technique.
Wait, the chair recognizes the shades of an HMA.
That's a very new statute where zoning ordinance amendments can originate from the Board of Selectmen.
And there actually was a hearing in front of municipal and county where a bill to actually repeal that power, but your voters gave you that power.
So in the municipalities where voters have provided their Board of Selectmen that power to propose zoning ordinance changes, you are correct.
So that means your voters gave you that permission permission but in the vast we didn't even know that there were any towns that uh that actually had done that power we've been wondering if any have done it so at least we know of one but in most municipalities we didn't know we couldn't the select would have been running this since 1815 well that's a um because we didn't even have zoning until about 25 years ago so well what passed for zoning was a selectman put something on the warrant or by petition.
The great John Locke said that governments are only legitimate in that we give our popular consent.
So I think even when rules have been broken, if everybody goes along with it, apparently that's what happens.
So let me, because I don't want to keep us for four hours.
Let's can we agree that the language which I'm basing on what I heard from everyone, I think, and what I got on a different bill from OLS, that governing body or local land use board.
Does that cover what we need to cover for the entity offering the evidence i think you want to add legislative because some if you if you put that rule in front of troy they'd be which is where i live or fitz william which i represent they'd be going governing body what the hell is that uh representative bolear yeah so uh this was this was something that, you know, when I was just trying to maintain the spirit of this, but, you know, I just took a stab at, you know, how would I revise this bill?
And I left it at a local legislative body of a city, town, or county in which there are located unincorporated towns or unorganized places.
And that was the language that the other part of the RSA used, because as far as I imagine it, adopting or enforcing any of these extraordinary restrictions, that authority is going to, whatever that restriction is, is going to have to originate in a legislative body.
So whatever it is, I thought legislative body, but I would.
But we can't prohibit people from voting on something right so they can't they can adopt right uh but but it wouldn't be enforceable if we word it a different way um so we could we could take out adopt and say we could say shall not enforce any extraordinary you know so i think it's more because you can just say municipality for that matter and it's more in terms of where the ordinance is a municipality may not enforce an ordinance that um without and i think the main thing is saying which body is the one that's providing the evidence.
And so that's,dy is do you have a comment oh okay how about we we restructure it to say in such a way that uh whatever method a municipality or county has adopted for planning and it shall we're so we're not changing that methodology so if you're no you're just saying like however you adopt whatever you're doing how whenever you can't do this right that's that's accurate i mean it's more important to say which body the evidence is coming out of is it the planning board is it the select board and i think saying governing body or local land use board covers both of those and town council and anything else.
All of those are either a local land use board or a governing body.
Yeah, I was just going to add, you know, maybe we should take it to where, you know, go over some of the changes you have and then some of the things I have.
Because I came out this from, I think, a different angle.
Okay.
All right.
So one of the – so I'm just going to keep working through this.
And if you don't mind, just because I'm not, I'm looking at mine, if you want to interject when I get to a place where you have a different, like a different.
Okay.
All right.
So one of the questions was, what is empirical evidence?
Empirical evidence is by the way, it's tested of it.
It's, it's fact.
It's like it happens in the real world.
It's not theoretical.
Empirical is something that's existing, not theoretical, but the way Montana, because Montana had a similar bill.
I didn't realize that they had a similar bill.
So great minds.
Montana has very specific specific and I think the intent of the committee is to provide a very high bar for that evidence.
Right.
So we don't want just any old like, you know, Time magazine article thrown in there.
And that's the evidence.
So they have detailed written findings of fact, including quantitative and empirical evidence of the best current scientific understanding published by nonpartisan peer review source.
And then if you go down a little bit later, we'll get back to a grieved person because that RSA is not correct anymore since we're taking it to the superior court instead of ZBA.
it says that they have to demonstrate through clear and convincing evidence that the challenge ordinance is directly necessary, narrowly tailored, and the least restrictive means to promote the government interest in public health and safety.
So those three things come out of Montana language, and that sets a really high bar.
And that enforcement will be stayed until the appeal.
Yeah, on the empirical evidence issue, which I think is good, I was thinking, my thought has been on this, it should include language that says, shall include but not be limited to and give examples of statistical information available from governmental research, third party, some give a list of things so that we're not, again, not dealing with a Newsweek article or a Time Magazine article or, you know, my son's eighth grade report on trees.
So I'm imagining government departments, institutions, public university research.
How about I answer that by sending you an email with what I think the right word should be.
All right.
So I have a really good idea of doing something.
Yeah.
Did you want to say it?
So just the whole narrowly tailored least restrictive means to me, like they're going for the strict scrutiny standard of, you know, when judicial review, whereas currently in New Hampshire, it's the.
I'm, I'm drawing a total blank here.
It is the it's the least restrictive legal review standard.
I think it's the reasonable basis standard.
So there's three.
There's strict scrutiny, intermediate scrutiny, and reasonable basis.
Currently, we're at the lowest.
This is trying to flip it to the highest, which I think because courts view that as they understand that language, that's going to raise the evidentiary bar.
So instead of us trying to – and this is kind of why mine is so much shorter.
It's not that the spirit is different.
It's that we are putting this higher standard in the statute.
But in terms of rules of evidence and weighing the evidence, we should, in my opinion, leave it for the judicial branch to, you know, do that job because they've already kind of carved a path to have these ordinances subjected to higher scrutiny.
Right.
So the, I don't know if this is the language you were thinking of, but in the original bill, it was the findings that they would find by preponderance of the evidence.
And that's like the really low level of evidence.
Right, right.
Whereas clear and convincing evidence is a higher bar.
Right.
So that's in terms of the evidentiary standard.
But there's separately when you are doing a challenge like Institute for Justice does a lot of challenges to state regulations and stuff stuff like that when you are putting a constitutional challenge against a statute you are looking um this is the standard that applies when you're saying does this statute violate you know somebody's constant you know um either equal protection or substantial due process or whatever so it is another legal standard just like the standard for evidence a legal standard, but they're two separate.
It's kind of where the burden is.
Yeah.
So that's another thing too.
Yes.
It's where the burden is allocated.
So in strict scrutiny, I believe the government has the burden of proof, whereas on rational basis, it is not the government.
Does anything you're saying, are you proposing a change to that first paragraph?
Roman number one?
Yeah.
So what I was kind of thinking was let's just short circuit a lot of this in terms of, okay, here's what kind of study you have to have.
Is it peer reviews?
that and so let's let's go straight to the heart of it which is right now what we have in new hampshire is you can enact any zoning ordinance you want um as long as it as long as it's you know as long as it's under an authority that you have under the zoning enabling act but also that it can pass this um this uh rational basis standard so what i proposed was let's say for these certain things, if what you're doing, if you're creating this extraordinary restriction on residential property, then in that instance, that particular regulation, you're not going to have this lowest standard.
You're going to have, and I wrote the intermediate standard, so we'd have it for reference, but I was actually going to leave it up to the subcommittee to decide whether it would be strict scrutiny or intermediate scrutiny, but a higher level of scrutiny when these certain things are triggered.
And also the basis for those restrictions in the draft that I have, I have it as health and safety.
And the reason why is because general welfare is this giant door that the court has opened.
That's in the original bill.
I didn't include general welfare in the original bill because it's a huge nebulous term that, you know, my property values would fall under, right?
And I even tried, there was comment during the hearing that, well, you know, the term usually is health, safety, and general welfare.
So can you include general welfare?
And I said, only if we very, very tightly defined it.
And I tried with IJ and Mercatus to take a stab at tightly defining general welfare.
And no matter how we did it, there were giant, you know, you could foresee a town coming up with any number.
I tried to say it had to deal with environmental pollution of noise, light, air, water.
And they're like, we were all coming up with ways that a town could get around that.
So we just decided to go with the original version, which left out general welfare entirely.
And I'm fine with putting strict scrutiny.
And I think what you're saying is that belongs in the appeals language.
I was saying, you know, the way I had it was, let's just have it in terms of the actual authority, which is the town has the authority under the zoning ordinance are under the zoning enabling act.
The town has the authority to enact, you know, health, safety, general welfare, and it has a list of certain things.
I was going to take that and said, yes, you have that authority.
However, if it implicates one of these extraordinary restrictions, your authority is narrowed, and it has to be either health or safety, and it has to be at a higher standard, either intermediate scrutiny or strict scrutiny.
So that doesn't necessitate any appeals.
In my mind, it doesn't necessarily.
Well, you need an appeal.
You need an appeals because it'll be representative Helen.
So I was just going to say, because you're doing health and safety of the community.
So I was going to say, can you reference 674-17, which is the purposes of zoning?
Because when you're talking about the enabling legislation, what you're supposed to do when you do zoning is follow 674.17, which is this is the purpose of zoning.
So what you're putting in are in that it's not just, well, health and safety is in there, but it lists like to lessen congestion.
Of course, security, safety from fire, panic, and dangers, promote health and general welfare, adequate light and air.
So I think we should reference the thing.
The reason you do your zoning is because of 674.
The thing that you're supposed to be doing is 674.17.
So can we reference what you're supposed to be doing?
Well, I'm not opposed to referencing it, but you just said general welfare in the list.
And the nebulousness of that list is kind of the problem because if it wasn't a problem, we wouldn't have the zoning situation we have now.
Right?
The fact that that list is, I mean, that brings up a whole other thing.
We could go after that list and tighten up that list directly.
But I think that's, you know, kind of broader scope than just saying specific.
I know, calm, calm, it's okay.
It's like, leave it alone.
Leave 674 alone.
Actually, this is in 674.17.
So this is in the same section of law.
But the point being that we, the point of this bill is to create this extraordinary restrictions concept.
And that will be a bucket and what we put in that bucket we can decide now and later and what have you but um we want this concept that extraordinary restrictions are a thing and we can define what that thing is but they need to be treated differently than other ordinances um i guess I'm still struggling to understand what change you're trying to make here, Representative Bollier.
Do you have the specific language change?
Yeah.
Well, so what I was going to say is I put the intermediate scrutiny standard in mind, but I'd be happy to do the strict scrutiny standard, which is the language that you have about the narrowly tailored and least restrictive means.
To me, that's coming from a strict scrutiny standard, and we can actually – I think New Hampshire, it's compelling government interest and must be necessary to the accomplishment of its legitimate purpose.
I mean, it's legalese, but a court will definitely know what this means and what the standard of review is and what kind of evidence the government needs to bring forward, and it is a very high standard.
So I think by doing that, we don't have to go into the weeds about, well, is this empirical?
Is this?
because me, you know, the way the statute is currently proposed, some of this, I think, you know, the town is going to choke on, the courts are going to choke on, and there's going to be a lot of opportunities for attorneys to litigate.
well, what exactly does this mean?
Whereas this, my proposal is let's do something that courts and attorneys already know and understand, but it is going to accomplish the spirit of this, which is if you're doing an extraordinary restriction, then you need to have strict scrutiny.
You have a compelling government.
It does say compelling government interest in the amendment.
But I don't necessarily buy the idea that not requiring this high level of fact finding is going to be equally a check on the towns as requiring it.
I think requiring it is a type of check in and of itself because the town's far less likely to even attempt to pass something if they can't get the research and they can't show their work.
So they're not even going to attempt it.
And also, like, if they know that that fact isn't going to hold up in court, they're not likely to do it.
Right.
So I think that not having it at all opens the door more than having it.
Does anybody else want to weigh in, Representative Axton?
Well, yeah, I agree with your reasoning.
I wanted to come back to the two proposals.
And so I'm feeling, I'm thinking that Representative Bolio's revisions, which are.
I like simpler.
And so I think on the rework that I'm going to call yours, you're trying to fix this, which would be the way I would kind of go, but I'm not sure simpler isn't better in terms of getting it out there, getting it through both getting it signed and most importantly if it if all of that happens getting it so that the towns understand it sometimes this is this is like less is more situation just say you can't do this stuff and you have to back up your work, and you can take it from there.
Representative Bowling?
Well, the other thing I wanted to say is that if you have this strict scrutiny standard in here and a town just ignores it, then the town has basically set themselves up for whatever their extraordinary restriction is to get struck down by the courts.
Well, I mean, that's kind of where I didn't really buy the argument that the courts are going to get choked up on these things because you're providing more evidence and more standard than if you don't provide that.
Then that means to me that the courts are going to get more choked up on that because they have less definition to go by.
No.
I mean, a big function of the court is to weigh the evidence and to understand, OK, what is a compelling government interest?
And there's a very big body of case law which has developed about, well, what kind of evidence meets that burden?
What kind of evidence would meet strict scrutiny?
And because strict scrutiny is tied into things like civil rights and things like that, it is a very high standard.
It's not a standard that I think the court would arbitrarily chip away on, but it's also, you know, by making this simpler, there's less possible, I think, objection when you take this to the entire legislative body or the committee, because I think a lot of people said, well, what is empirical or, well, what is scientific, like non-peer?
I mean, that's things that people can really, I think, debate and courts can debate because it's not a legally established standard.
And I mean, I know I'm probably talking more like an attorney here, but.
Well, I guess that's a good question.
Are there any attorneys here?
Oh, OK.
You are.
OK, because this was actually written by the draft before you, the amendment draft.
One attorney through IJ and one through Mercatus.
So it's two attorneys that dealt with that.
I'll be it.
I don't.
The one through IJ has practiced in New Hampshire.
I don't think the one.
And yeah.
And I mean, I wouldn't hold myself out as like, oh, yes, I'm a municipal law attorney or anything like that.
I will say if you get three attorneys, you'll get four different opinions.
Right.
At least.
So, you know, just as a selectman and a guy who's developed lands, and I've watched the back and forth that goes on, I think that there would be would be a if you wound up in superior court in cheshire county and you had passed some ordinance some restrictive ordinance counter with this law on the books and your reasoning was nothing more than nimbyism i don't want it my backyard, I think the court would be able to see through that very confident.
A big piece that seemed to resonate and I think will resonate in the Senate, the other body, is the show your work concept.
And I think that including the fact-finding and having a high standard for that fact-finding is the show your work heart.
That's the important piece of it.
So I'm really kind of reluctant to give up on the idea of them having to show the science.
I don't disagree with you on that.
I think you can do that, but I think you can have a shorter version of that which is the this proposed version and attorney abolio's version versus the longer more complicated version i like simple not that different it's it's it's like okay the the paragraph one is uh you have like maybe two sentences in this one albeit it looks long because we have some struck out pieces but it's um it's you know maybe four sentences instead of two so i personally really love the show your work and i think that that that sounds really good um and that's one of the things like when i was drafting i like stayed until one of the morning working on this um that was one of the things where i really liked that piece.
The reason I settled on this, you know, is because I think it's easier for, so some people are going to like the show your work idea.
Other people are going to say, what are you doing to my local control?
And, you know, oh, great.
Now, every time we want to change something, the town's going to have to pay for this expensive study and all these experts.
And that is going to get a lot of the fiscal hawks to come out against it in droves.
So I was thinking, okay, if you have a strict scrutiny standard, they are going to have to show their work.
They can't just come up with a reasonable basis or ad hoc or whatever.
They're actually going to have to say, look, in order to accomplish this health or safety goal, this is the lightest touch that we have to do.
And they're going to have to bring darn good evidence.
And when I was looking at some of the case law about this, they were talking about, okay, well, we did a scientific study and we had experts and all of this other stuff.
That's the kind of evidence that a municipality is naturally going to want to bring in order to enforce their ordinance.
So I think by doing this, what you want, which is this high-quality scientific empirical evidence that the towns are not just acting arbitrarily, I think will come with the higher standard.
But we don't need to write it out in statute because I think if you write it out in statute, it's kind of like the more words you give attorneys to work with, the more ways they're going to say, well, actually an empirical study means this or this isn't workable or this is – or you're going to – what will more likely happen is if it's too complicated for people to see and they'll say, oh, now towns have to pay for studies to enact zoning.
I'm going to vote against that.
I really wanted something that had good opportunity to actually happen, in my opinion.
I mean, all the points are well taken.
I don't think that it means that they have to pay for a study.
I don't think it's implying that.
And I think anybody who argues that would be not arguing in good faith.
But that happens quite frequently, as we know.
Does anybody else have any other, anybody else who hasn't, anybody else want to weigh in on the question of to show your work or not show your work?
I like the simpler version.
Same reason as Representative Bolio says.
The simpler, the better.
Planning boards are going to look at that and say, forget it, I'm not doing it.
That's kind of the point, actually.
Yeah, but they're going to do their zoning changes anyway, and then setting themselves up for lawsuits or whatever.
But I don't think it's going to stop anybody.
Representative Hicks.
So I was just thinking of planning boards and the finding of facts, and maybe Brody can weigh in on this.
So planning board meetings, I don't know when it started, but we're required now to state our findings of fact before we make a decision.
And it is simply that.
Like we have to announce what the findings of fact are to go along with, but they are not necessarily empirical.
Right.
was just thinking pretty simple but in a it could be challenged if our findings of fact were not actual facts right if we made our decisions based on something that wasn't presented as testimony or evidence but if it's challenged and we had the language then the court could easily strike it down like you clearly weren't using empirical, quantitative evidence from a peer-reviewed source.
You clearly weren't doing this.
But if they didn't have that language, then finding a fact is just a finding a fact.
And the court won't know what to do with it and will have more of a question.
And that's kind of what I'm arguing to keep it in for.
But if I outnumbered then I am outnumbered like like you said I think this this this builds a framework and if if we if this actually makes it through and this becomes New Hampshire law and very quickly we're going to start to see a body of case law develop and if that is developing in a way that is not helpful then we can revisit this this and say, no, actually, we want this additional evidentiary standard or something like that.
But I think this really, I, you know, I think this really puts the foot in the door to actually, you know, to have, hey, strict scrutiny for extraordinary restrictions of residential property.
I mean, that, that's a huge, I think, if you are for loosening some of the zoning, you know, the overzealous zoning, I think that's a pretty powerful tool that you're giving, you know, people to challenge that.
I mean, yeah, it's better than what we have, but the very, the idea that you just said that like, well, if they start not finding in their, you know, the better direction, then, you know, then we can revisit it.
That's kind of what's been happening for the last hundred years that we're trying to change, right?
Is the fact that the momentum has always been against people.
Yeah, go ahead.
So the body of case law has always been, you know, you know, just, you know, reasonable.
It's always been the lowest, you know, standard.
And, you know, somewhat recently, the New Hampshire Supreme Court actually made it even lower, you know, in terms of rational basis, you don't even have to look, I think, at, you know, whether anybody's individual rights are implicated.
So the fact is, is that if the court were to do something that, you know, weaken strict scrutiny, like I said, it's tied to civil rights law.
They're not going to do that because of all the other things that it's tied into.
So I think this would I think this would be a pretty, pretty powerful tool.
And it would make, you know, the towns have to show their work, you know, when they go to court, if it gets challenged or better yet, they just don't enforce and say, you know what, we don't want to, you know, we don't actually have a good reason that would survive strict security after talking to town council about our burden of proof on this.
We're just not going to enforce our restriction that requires, you know, a 10-acre minimum.
I think you'll find a lot of that happening.
Okay, so once again, I want to not get too beleaguered onto one point because we haven't even gotten to the actual bucket.
But I will say that, and so this is halfway through the first paragraph, and maybe we can revisit it.
It sounds like most of the people on the subcommittee don't want to include actual fact finding requirement in this.
Am I correct?
Well, it looks like the three Republicans agree.
Do I have anything from Democrats?
Do I need to take an official vote?
Well.
I mean, you were telling me to include like a list including but not limited.
I don't know.
official vote well i mean you were telling me to include like a list including but not limited yeah i'm i'm i i like the shorter version but i really think that we should have i think it is reasonable to say i think you need to give an example and say it can be but not limited to you know reports from the New Hampshire so you're saying give an example but then don't say quantitative and empirical of best current scientific understanding from a nonpartisan I think that's the more important piece than the example.
Right.
See, my concern is if you say the empirical part, I don't want to say you're shooting over people's heads, but I think...
I mean, they have Webster's, right?
They can look it up if they...
Yeah, one would hope.
Well, the courts have Merriam-Webster 3rd edition that they have to...
I don't want it to have to go that far so I think you know I you know what do I think I hate to be the guy sitting on the fence uh but I guess I am I think it needs to have some definition and some limitation some kind I don't want some at least have some definition but it should be there there should be some, I'm concerned about saying empirical evidence quantitative or empirical evidence why does because sometimes in planning and zoning it doesn't always work that way so before I recognize Mr.
Deshaies, maybe I can try with the other lawyers and maybe I bring Rep.
Bullier into that conversation as a lawyer and try to get some happy medium between these two.
Does that sound okay?
And since that's not a quorum of the subcommittee, that should be fine to do.
Mr.
DeShayes of NHMA.
Thank you, Madam Chairwoman.
So I do just want to, regarding the evidence, our biggest concern about requiring the evidence and how it would be defined would be developers or those who are property owners and the municipalities in court trying to determine what is actual empirical evidence what is a peer-reviewed source what kinds of it gets you get into a whole gray area where you'd be litigating on what you're even allowed to litigate okay and so that's some of our that's some of our biggest concerns with and i we understand the intent, but I do just want to flag that as that.
Well, and just so we're on the same page, we appreciate that you're helping with the technicalities of the language, but you are against the intent of the bill itself.
No, I understand, but I am pointing.
So just trying to, if the goal is to limit the amount of times that developers and municipalities are in court when you're trying to figure out what kind of information is going to be required for municipalities to report and they make these ordinance changes, I think that, I think it might end up being counterintuitive in some ways, but that's just, you know, just flagging that it might be, it might make more sense to get away from more of the what exactly is the information and having these more ambiguous terms that could be interpreted differently as case laws developed.
Thank you for your input.
So just so we're clear, he's the lawyer.
I have the degree in molecular biology.
Empirical and quantitative and peer-reviewed are not disputable terms.
They are very clear terms.
They are well understood.
So I know that people outside the science community may be like, what does this mean?
But quantitative means numbers.
Empirical means real world as opposed to theory.
And peer-reviewed means literally you had peers repeat your process.
And so to my point, in the world of planning and zoning and small towns which we've got lots of we don't have good empirical evidence that adding a four-unit apartment building on a two-acre lot is either good or bad no the the town doesn't have to generate that evidence if they're going to somebody, they have to cite some evidence that exists.
They don't have to generate it.
And so that's my point.
And so we should give some guidance because I believe that the worst thing we can do is create a bill that creates a law that sends everybody to court for four years and nothing gets done.
And that would be worse than, you know, this is in the rule of don't make things worse.
And I don't want to.
And I think the idea is a good, like I said, in the initial hearing, I think there's a lot of good in this.
This is like a direction we should go.
So now we're in the nasty part.
Fill out the, you know, I'm an economist.
I have that degree.
And so we just assume the answer and then find facts that suit it.
That sounds right, Representative Belier.
I just, you know, in terms of, because I agree, quantitative empirical evidence, especially if it went to a peer-reviewed source, I mean to me that is great evidence if you're trying to prove something and you're going to court.
So I think that is good evidence.
I think that my bigger concern here is that when you have towns that are going to figure out how to grapple with this, if it passes as written, then you're going to have towns say, well, we need to commission a study and it needs to follow these standards and all this other stuff.
And what's going to happen is if we take this bill, I think, to the full house, we're going to have a lot of people who are going to be opposed to it because they're going to say, well, this is going to mandate my small town pay for a very, very expensive study.
You know, so I think that's where this bill is going to get tripped up, even though I like show your work.
I like, you know, empirical evidence.
It doesn't say that.
And why do you think that it would be read as that.
Well, but no, I mean, that's a claim, unfunded mandate, right?
But like it literally does, you can open a book and cite the evidence.
You don't have to do the study.
That's not the world that we live in in small towns.
They don't have to pass the ordinance.
That's the thing.
It's not an unfunded mandate because they don't have to pass the ordinance.
You're going to, they're going to fight about it and they're going to sue each other.
That's what thing.
It's not an unfunded mandate because they don't have to pass the ordinance.
You're going to they're going to fight about it and they're going to sue each other.
That's what they're going to do.
So, Mike, somebody said that the goal, maybe it was Mr.
Deshaies, if the goal is to not have people in court.
My goal is to not restrict people's ability to live.
The court thing is secondary to me.
And while I am sympathetic, I care more about making sure people can live.
So I don't see why, I mean, it seems like we're spending a lot of time on this one sentence of quantitative empirical evidence, the best current scientific understanding by quantitative empirical peer reviewed.
I mean, the other thing I'm thinking about is if, you know, the court got this and it says, okay, it's dictating what kind of evidence can be used.
Would there be some kind of due process or constitutional challenge that the court would use to just strike down the language altogether?
I mean I don't – The language of the law you mean?
The quantitative – Quantitative evidence standard if there's – I don't – So – Wait.
Sorry.
I think we're going violent agreement but you know you the idea is we don't want the towns to come up with some bullshit reason on why you can't do something right you've got to have a so we all agree on Now we have to come out – come up with a way that says in plain language that's supportable in court, anybody with an eighth grade education can read it and go, oh, I get it.
So – That's where we're trying to – that's the – Right.
And since we've spent 20 minutes on the first sentence, then I am going to hope that we can move on to the rest of the bill.
Is it in Representative Bowley or you had your hand up?
Was there a last thing to?
The only last thing is, I mean, I don't know so much about like an eighth grade education, but I can tell you my intention was, you know, by by just calling out very clearly what the standard is and saying, look, if you're going to do health or safety and it is, you know, an extraordinary restriction, then it's, you know, it's either going to be strict scrutiny or intermediate scrutiny.
I think up to the committee to decide.
Sounds like we're talking a lot about strict scrutiny, which is a higher standard, which is great.
I don't know if necessarily the town will know that, but any town council will definitely be able to tell them whether – they'll give them a good idea.
They'll give them a good legal opinion as to does this ordinance pass muster or not.
Right.
And the more daunting the task is, the less likely they're going to try it.
But I think in terms of moving past, I think the spirit of this subcommittee and the spirit of the committee as a whole, and anybody's free to disagree with me, is to put the strictest scrutiny, strictest standard in general on this.
Like you absolutely have to show this is directly necessary, narrowly tailored, and least restrictive, which is the language in this thing.
So my suggestion, again, is that I get Bollier who as an attorney together with the other two attorneys who worked on this and merge those ideas together in the simplest version that still does what we want.
Cause I think we are in violent agreement about what we want to do.
Does that work if I get you together?
Yeah.
And the only reason I in mind I used intermediate scrutiny was because it is a higher standard.
And I think, you know, because I see Mr.
Deshaies over there like taking notes.
I think that taking his suspicious notes.
But the fact but the fact is, is subjecting towns to strict scrutiny.
I mean, that is a pretty high burden.
That's an extremely high burden.
And I don't know if, you know, the full legislature would see this as, you know, okay, this is an attack on local control.
I think that intermediate, I know we probably do water things down too much in this, in this committee, but it might be a way to say, look, we're not trying to override local control.
We're trying to strike a balance.
And I'm going to bring you and the other two lawyers together.
I'm going to let you all lawyerly duke it out in your lawyerly ways, and then we'll figure out the best for that one section.
We all good with yous doing that and moving on?
Okay, great.
So the idea was that it would no longer get appealed to the ZBA, and so it would be going to superior court, which means that an aggrieved person under RSA 675 is no longer valid because that's the ZBA section.
So it would just be an aggrieved person whose property rights are affected by the ordinance.
Yes.
So I did take that out in mind, and the reason why is to give the ZBA a chance to listen to their town council and say, hey, before we go to Superior Court and there's an expensive lawsuit, you might want to have another chance to think about this.
And the way the rest of the RSA is written, it contemplates going going to the zba first so i don't think there's any harm in giving the zba a chance to reverse themselves and then go to superior court okay can we add that to the agenda for the lawyer meeting all right yes representative axel now that that's sort of what i wanted to say you know the intent of the z the ZBAs, you can always go to superior court.
This is America.
You can always sue people.
But the intent of the ZBAs in New Hampshire and the way they function is to not have to go to superior court.
So if you have a disagreement or an issue at the planning board, rather than have to go through the expense and time of going to superior court, I have a cheap option, which is to go before the ZBA.
And then I can appeal a decision of the ZBA.
So I think you're making it harder for the poorer petitioner to get something changed if you remove that intermediate step of the ZBA.
That's a point well taken.
Again, I had the lawyers do this.
They did it.
They said, you know what?
Let's just do straight to Superior Court.
So I'm just going to say all of paragraph one.
We're going to fine tune because I think we're all in agreement in the spirit.
Is that good with everyone?
Okay.
Paragraph two.
We're here.
And I'm going to try to do side by side.
For the purpose of this section, extraordinary restriction of residential property means any ordinance that restricts, regulates, or permits, property used, or proposed for residential purposes.
I said, and that has, and you said, and that includes any of the following.
So we'll just go line by line.
It doesn't look like, I can't tell what you, if, if you changed anything.
Okay.
So really my only change was instead of limitation, I put restriction just so the wording was more consistent throughout the statute.
So I actually did that on a previous version of this Google doc and I don't know how it, so anyway, I did the same thing.
the same thing okay and then the only other thing was um um the uh the the fees one and then the um the camping one I really I like the spirit of that one my concern with those because I completely understand and I where you're where you're coming from on that and I think that is a good idea but I think that if people view this bill as something that's going to legalize you know people camping out on their property year-round or something like that I think we'll get a lot bigger fight on the floor and it'll get maybe some people who would vote for it actually against it because it'll take what really what this bill is about and it'll create this ancillary fight about you know camping and all that other stuff if this is something that i think we should revisit because i do think this is an issue um and it is a restriction on a residential use of property but i think that's maybe something where once we have this bucket established in the future add add these sort of things into the bucket.
So if I can, because we changed that piece to make it a little bit, they actually changed a few of these.
So let me go back to this version with the two organizations.
The first one is any minimum square footage requirement for a dwelling or unit in excess of 200 square feet or the square footage required to meet the state building code whichever is greater i think the state building code for says 200 square feet which is why we lifted that lot size requirement over five acres per primary dwelling unit they added per primary dwelling unit um so you if you were to have the way it was written before it because it said per unit if you had a house with anU, then that would double your lot minimum until 10, right?
So this keeps it at five.
Then, because they were getting ambitious, the ones that are underlined, they are completely new and they added those.
For lots served by municipal water and sewer, and then they went on with frontage requirements over 50 feet, minimum square of greater than 50 by 50 feet for the plot, I presume.
Minimum lot size of greater than 2,500 square feet or restrictions that, I mean, they really were like, let's see what we can get in this bucket.
Limitation on residential use of commercially zoned lots, which I think we're all in agreement on when just passed the bill.
limitation on the in-home business use of commercially zoned lots, which I think we're all in agreement on when just passed the bill.
Limitation on the in-home business use of residentially zoned lots, provided such business use does not violate noise pollution, garbage, and light ordinances.
Do you think that covers what we need to cover?
Violate noise pollution.
Or, yeah.
All of those are anecdotes necessarily.
Right.
I didn't see the language about the surf, I was for water and suing.
No, that's entirely new.
Bye, Al.
Adding too much.
Asking for too much.
It was a wish list, and I just made sure to underline what they added because the colors weren't coming up in the black and white, so I was just underlining to make sure that you knew that that was the part that they were adding is entirely new.
Limitation on whether the dwelling unit is built on or off-site, which for some reason was included in the definition at the beginning in the previous version, local amendments, the state building code and, you know, stop me if I don't see your hand go up.
Let me local amendments to the state building code or state fire code regarding materials or methods of construction.
That's where we get into things like Quonsets, 3D printed homes, manufactured homes, which impact residential buildings if not more than four units.
Fees on variance.
I think that you kept that the same use.
Did you take it out entirely?
Okay.
so the fee, like, okay, but I feel pretty strongly about some of the camping stuff.
And I know that there's like a stigma thing, but let's just, okay.
So mine, if you flip over the page, changes it to like two different ones that one is the amount of time a property owner or authorized owner may camp on a property and a vehicle or other structure, provided that the ordinance may restrict the operation of a camping business that offers campsites in exchange for money.
And then same thing on the other one, the number of persons camping is they can have an ordinance that requires as long as it's not less than four per acre so you can say you can't have 10 people on an acre you can't have five people but you can't go under four um and also you can still restrict a camping business does that at all help that doesn't help your concern whatsoever no thank you so this is a non-starter for me and conquered just the campaign so i would i would um support representative bolio's um you know his version of not including this when we spoke previously your worries seemed to be around like homeless encampments but those people don't have legal access to those lands.
This would create a potential situation where people would allow people to camp on their property indefinitely in somebody else's backyard, essentially, and the neighbor could not do anything about that.
Well, only if it's four or fewer people per acre.
Even in Troy, this is going to be an issue.
Okay, so let's start from the beginning.
I feel it's very important.
So how about if we just restrict it to the owner-occupier?
Why wouldn't the owner-occupier be able to camp?
Only the owner.
If you are the owner of that land, then you're allowed to camp on your own land.
Why can't you do that now?
Because towns are literally saying you can't camp longer than three months on your own land.
So, that's fine.
Owner-occupier.
All right.
Owner.
Property owner.
The property owner, right.
You are the person camping and yours is the name on the deed.
Do we include, like, how do we say the family of that person?
Well, let's stick with this part first before we go to that part.
So here's, as the devil's advocate here, so I'm a selectman, and you want to go camp on your land.
And it's on a class six road, which currently is not buildable.
Not buildable.
In my town.
Some towns it is.
and and so and you now decide you want to go camp out there semi-indefinitely and we have no way of restricting that due to lack of water sewer whatever else seems important and so if if the way i'm reading what or what we're saying here is if i pass a bill that says the owner property owner and their family can use the property for an unrestricted amount of time they could camp on the property for 15 years right so i think you're gonna have a problem with that i mean i mean that's what i want well i gather that's what i want but like yeah representative so to the point about you know health safety if we if you're going to get a building permit to build a home currently and i this is probably where you're going with this but if you don't have septic or well you're not gonna be able to build that home right right so the reason for that is likely health and safety right so the camping then some they might say you must have a well and septic right to camp and then if they could prove that that was necessary which they may very well may be able to do then they would be set to have that ordinance Thank you.
might say you must have a whale and septic in order to camp.
And then if they could prove that that was necessary, which they may very well may be able to do, then they would be set to have that ordinance.
And that's the beautiful part of this concept is we, I think when we're getting into the items in the bucket, we're imagining bans.
We're not banning the town from setting these ordinances.
We're just saying it's a higher threshold for these because it's extraordinary.
I struggle with this because I deal with the reality of a small New England town that alternates between relative prosperity and occasional not.
And judgment has not been good judgment and zoning and common sense have not been the driving forces in the last 80 years in the towns in my region.
So, and I have, in my town right now, I can tell you as a selectman, we are engaged in trying to prevent a man who has created a health hazard, and he insists that he has the right to live on his camp on his property.
And there's no well, there's no septic.
He's encroached on his neighbors.
I mean, I want to get you into the bottom line is it's not going to sell a p it's not going to sell well in alistad and actworth and troy and fitzwilliam it's not what we we don't need more people living in the woods i mean there's there's a couple aspects when we had the occupancy limit bill there were red flags going off when people started to talk weird about students and I'm having some of those same red flags go off.
We don't like these people living in the woods.
They're weird kind of red flags.
And I want to separate that from the very real concern for health and safety.
If it is health and safety, if they are having like piles of feces build up, for example, if they're pouring like gallons upon gallons of soapy water or otherwise polluted water into your watershed for a sensitive stream or what have you that's a real concern and in that case they can set that ordinance they can say well you have to have a septic you have to have a well or you have to prove that you are you know having your stuff come and pumped, you have to have a septic, you have to have a well, or you have to prove that you are, you know, having your stuff come and pumped your, your whatever the, yeah, not septic.
Um, what's it called?
Like when you have a port-a-potty, they'll come and pump that.
Right.
And yeah, whatever it is, you're, you prove that you have it, have it properly disposed.
So we could add owner-occupier and then in addition to that, add some verbiage around water and septic or yes.
So I was just going to say like if you own the property and you want to camp out and you are genuinely camping, you're not creating an or you know unsanitary situation but you're legitimately camping on your own property i mean new hampshire is a live free or die state i think you should probably be able to camp on your own property there's a lot of beautiful parts of new hampshire to camp on my problem my problem with and the reason i took it out in my first one is and we've already had it in the subcommittee, we'll have this problem in the committee and we'll have this problem in the full house, is that every additional thing that you put in this bucket is another reason for somebody to say no.
So I want to be very judicious with what we put in this bucket.
So that's why I'm saying that might be something to where I would love it.
And there's a lot of things that I would love to say to us.
I'm super passionate about the camping thing.
I'm super, because it is quickly becoming people's only option.
So if we have to narrowly, narrowly define it, if we have to put in something around water and septic, I still would like to try to keep it in.
Yes.
Representative Plaxile.
I'll be very straightforward about it.
I think it belongs in a separate bill so that all of the funky little details can be worked out about it.
And I won't vote for this with the camping.
You will.
Are you saying you will not vote for it?
It has the camping in it at all.
Any any no matter how we have camping ordinances in most all of our towns and i'm sure they're all various i mean my town i think is fairly liberal you can apply to the selectmen i i have personally signed off on two permits for people to camp on their own property so in my town it's not a problem i understand it in the city of concord it may very well be a problem uh i think you're going to have only if each of those homeless people owned a piece of land i mean i and again i'm trying to be practical about it because there's a whole lot in this bill that i think is really helpful and good but i think i think this one is going to be i agree with representative bolio it's thing, and it's probably the hardest thing in here, and it has the most stigma attached to it.
And so the real politics part of this is put it in a separate bill and hash it out on its own.
Because it's going to drag this bill, if you think this bill is important, that's going to drag this bill down.
Representative Hicks.
So just, I have a 315 just oh sorry um i will so i generally agree with that i will support the bill if it's owner occupied um and it's limited to that i can justify that in concord okay okay but just to be very clear representative taxon no matter how it's worded, no matter how narrowly it's tailored, you won't support anything that talks about camping.
You just asked me to define infinity.
Of course, I'm sure it's a combination.
I don't get what you want to do.
I don't know that I think it's an evil and bad thing that you've ever done.
I think it's a mistake.
Does that make sense?
Yes.
And I agree.
I agree with that.
I think that...
It's the riskiest piece of the bill is what we're saying.
Yeah.
And I think there's a lot of good in this bill that we could probably get passed.
Okay.
I agree that this may sink it.
So the next two pieces are underlined and that is stuff that they added.
And this basically is repeating other bills that we had.
The, well, one of them is saying, and it was a whole new concept.
And what I'm, the temperature I'm taking, especially since we have a 315 stop is that we don't want to overcomplete.
We won't add more things to the bucket because the more we add, the worse it gets.
But just so you're aware of the concept, the concept is currently if someone were to build ADUs on their property, now they can't necessarily sell those ADUs as separate, like condo-wise.
And the great thing about being able to sell it is the fact that then you have, if you You have one house with two ADUs, if you condoize it and sell the units, you have two extra property owners, homeowners, whereas before you only had one homeowner.
So this was a concept.
It may be that if we get the bucket established this year, we can come back next year and add more things to the bucket.
But I just wanted to make that concept, put it in your brains as a little seed.
The last one he added was the, it's basically the 457 bill, the occupancy limit bill.
So it was just kind of like putting, making that occupancy limit an extraordinary restriction.
We can leave those out because I think that's what everybody's aiming for.
The rest of it is the appeals.
Are we good on that?
Or because we already said we're going to talk about adding the zoning board back in.
Yeah.
So Representative Bollier and I are going to have a meeting with the other two lawyers and then we're going to hash out that piece of it, that kind of the court piece.
And then the very last piece I added is paragraph 11, just saying that any municipal ordinance that currently is an extraordinary restriction once this passes would have 90 days for them to offer that fact finding, which is another reason we might want the fact finding.
And then it becomes unenforceable.
So if we presume all of that is the lawyer piece of it, then Representative Bollier and I will work on that separately.
Do you want to trust us to come up with the amendment or do you all want to have another subcommittee?
Okay, so just so you're, I can BCC everybody the amendment.
I can, we cannot discuss it on email because that's a notice meeting.
So one of the things I was thinking was maybe, you know, today they're on a different bill in this committee.
The subcommittee met at 9 o'clock just a little bit earlier.
So maybe if we do some more work on this, have a draft version BCC to everybody, and then we come ready to discuss that at like an earlier meeting.
And I think if there's broad, because it sounds like we're in agreement on the spirit and the sticking points.
I think if whatever, you know, that proposed language looks like if everybody's in agreement, then I think at nine o'clock subcommittee meeting, we could probably, you know, vote, vote it.
I think at 9 o'clock subcommittee meeting, we could probably, you know, vote it.
I think so.
I have to notice subcommittees before, like, I need 24 hours or 48 hours.
Yeah.
Or I could notice it for 945 and we could just take a vote and then we'll have something.
Okay.
All right.
You want to do that?
So next order of business is I'll grab Rep.
Bollier.
We'll hammer this out and then I'll notice another meeting and I'll send out the amendment.
Yes?
Yes.
Thank you.
bullier will will hammer this out and then i'll notice another meetings and i'll send out the amendment yes yes what is this what are you trying to do with this hundred dollars because i can tell you i just like for various but being two properties that i own and i don't almost surrounding properties but i have that it cost me 35351.
So I will be 100% honest.
The concept of this bill has been around, started in my head two years ago, and then I started getting a bunch of input from a bunch of different people who added a bunch of different things.
It could have come from the Honorable Josh O'Kella who helped me with this.
It could have come from several different people, but I don't remember who put it in.
It actually wasn't me.
I am much more passionate about the camping thing than I am about any variants.
Okay.
All right.
Well, that seems fine to me.
Well, so we're not taking an official vote.
This is just what we're doing.
And I will be emailing everybody, especially you, soon.
And with that, we'll adjourn this subcommittee.
I will notice for the next one.
All right.
Thank you.